Прошу вас проходити, щоб двері зачинились і ми могли вирушати далі. Дуже дякую.
Вітаю! Я Фатіма. Водійка автобуса. Сьогодні я вам покажу, як керувати 18-метровим електробусом вулицями Берліна.
На що доводиться звертати увагу? Чим відрізняється цей електробус від наших звичайних дизельних? І як їх заряджають?
Мені 28 років, я родом з прекрасної столиці - з Берліна. Це просто моє місто. Мені тут дуже добре. Я тут виросла, тут народилася.
І вже майже півтора року керую автобусом.
Моя мати теж часто була у роз’їздах і казала: вау, моя донька керуватиме такою гігантською машиною. Вона дуже, дуже пишалася.
І так, звичайно, родина також сказала: вау, ти наважилася це зробити? Ти така крута і в тебе все вийде.
Коли я вже деякий час поїздила, з’явилися ці нові електричні автобуси. Такі великі.
І насправді вже були думки: вау, проїхатися б на ньому! І ти така вже бачиш себе у ньому.
Як ти там сидиш і, так би мовити, пересуваєш цю штуковину вулицями Берліна.
Відрізняється цей автобус тим, що приладовою панеллю керує сенсорний екран. Праворуч ми маємо все, що потрібно для їзди, так би мовити.
Передачі - драйв, нейтралка і назад. Тут розташоване відчинення дверей. Але там в нас немає сенсорної поверхні, а кнопки, якими потрібно керувати.
Тут у нас спеціальне гальмо, за допомогою якого автобус повністю нахиляється.
Все, що, так би мовити, стосується повідомлень про помилки - наприклад, задіяно гальмо - відображається нижче.
Посередині швидкість, з якою ми рухаємось.
На самому початку нашого навчання, звичайно, ми пройшли курси, як керувати у найбільш енергоефективний спосіб.
І в цих електромобілях, звичайно, відіграють важливу роль другорядні пристрої, що споживають енергію.
Взимку це - обігрівач. Ці USB-слоти на задній частині салону.
Як це можна звести до мінімуму, цілком зрозуміло - подібно до дизельних автомобілів: без різких і занадто швидких запусків.
Своєчасне гальмування, раннє розпізнавання. Гаразд, зараз горить червоне світло, тобто більше не прискорюйтесь.
Все так само і з цими транспортними засобами.
Але при цьому це інший досвід водіння. У вас більше немає такого, так би мовити, важкого дизеля, який гуркотить під ногами.
Натомість все трохи еластичніше. Ви відчуваєте, що це сучасніше. Наче пливеш вулицями.
Нелегко маневрувати цими автобусами в умовах міського трафіку Берліна.
Дуже часто виникають ситуації, коли вам доводиться багато на що реагувати, швидко діяти і на все зважати.
Я взагалі-то з перукарського цеху. Я займалася цим протягом десяти років і багато спілкувалася з клієнтами. Я чула і деякі приватні історії.
Те саме трапляється тепер зі мною у роботі на автобусі. Приміром, коли я стою на зупинці і чекаю свого напарника на заміну.
Ти стоїш так в уніформі з таким обличчям, що літні жінки хотіли б підійти і трохи розповісти про свої клопоти.
Наш маршрут номер 200 - історичний. Ми їдемо через безліч відомих вулиць, багато відомих місць від Александерплац і Потсдамської площі до зоопарку.
І 200-ий маршрут нині повністю електричний.
Отже, на задньому плані ми бачимо ось такий пантограф, який заряджає наші електроавтобуси зверху за допомогою потужної системи зарядки.
Акумулятора вистачає приблизно на 35 хвилин їзди. А щоб повністю зарядити його, потрібно 7-8 хвилин.
Коли зарядний важіль опускається, а потім правильно закріплюється, це відображається на дисплеї, а це також світиться зеленим.
Означає, що в цей момент ми заряджаємось.
Звичайно, зараз тестуються різні типи автобусів. Час роботи батарей, дальність проїзду.
Тому, звичайно, ми ще не повністю змінилися, щоб мати змогу використати усі найкращі можливості для Берліна.
Завжди є окремі колеги, які ставляться скептично до усіх нових розробок і, так би мовити, відхиляють їх.
Або коли хтось намагається працювати над змінами, вони завжди проти.
Але моє покоління ці зміни справді підтримує, і колеги в моєму оточенні все це дуже добре сприйняли.
І мені не терпиться проїхати на електробусі якомога більше.
Це захопливо. Не минає дня, щоб увечері не прийти додому і не було, що розповісти.
Завжди відбуваються захоплюючі речі - і на дорозі, і в пробках. Ви бачите різні поліцейські операції, іноді навіть аварії.
Байдуже, куди ви їдете, завжди є, що подивитися. Тож ніколи не нудно.